well I I believe I believe you know as
any agnostic I believe that there are so
many things that are entirely unknowable
that it's is it's better to abandon
yourself to the wisdom of the universe
or its indifference as Albert Camus
would say you know is you can abandon
yourself to the cold embrace of of the
universe or it's warm embrace depending
on what why are you in but but there is
however like in fractals like in so many
things there are scales contained within
order an order to contain within chaos
and a constant flow between the two and
and I think that the beauty of
understanding that is that you
understand that there is a functional
model to the universe whether is
expanding contracting and therefore
completely changing the rules of time
and space and this and that and
generating everything that we consider
paranormal or spiritual I don't know but
there is a flow there is an order there
is a function to it and and I and I
think that that allows us to dream our
own mythologies so I have constructed my
own my own sort of personal religion you
know which doesn't depend on a guy in
the sky that I prayed to but that does
depend on trying to be as good a person
as I can be and I'm not a good person
all the time but I allow myself to to
understand that too and I just think
that you know that that would be the
fundamental belief that you know the
Greeks the Greeks used to say we should
we don't need good the government I need
good citizens and I think in the same
way religion and spirituality
it doesn't need a great church or it
doesn't you don't need to belong to a
great church you just need to try to be
a good man to a certain degree you know
as good
man as you can be whatever that measure
is be it you're a serial killer or war
hero or a Samaritan whatever you are be
be as good a man as you can be